-I'm very happy
to have you here now,
because you've been here befor
around Halloween.
You are a fan of Halloween
-I am.
-And --
-Well, yes.
-You...
[ Light laughter ]
I know your youngest son
is maybe -- is he
maybe outgrowing needing you
-No, I mean, yes.
I mean, he's not outgrowin
Halloween at all,
But he's certainly
outgrowing me.
-Gotcha.
-Which is sad.
-Do you like trick-or-treating
-Yeah, no, I love --
Yeah, no, I love Halloween
I've just been doing it
for so long.
I have a 30-year-old,
and then I have an 11-year-old
and I have a 26-year-old,
so I've never not --
-Did you space them out like
this to have more Halloweens
-For Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-For Halloween.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's just
how it turned out,
in terms of Halloween.
-But you knew right away.
You were like, "This is grea
for Halloween reasons."
-Yeah,
"This is going to work out."
-Yeah.
-Yes. I mean, you know,
as soon as the last one starte
to get a little bit older,
I realized
we better start working
on the replacement
for Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But, anyway, last year, he --
last year, my youngest son
you know, said,
"Dad, you know, I don't
really need you to" --
"Papa" he calls me --
"I don't really need you
to go trick-or-treating
with me."
I was devastated, really.
-Yeah.
Did you -- Had you already
bought a costume for yourself?
-Well, I've always had a costume
around the --
-The house?
-Yeah.
-I mean, we have a -- yes, yeah.
No, there's always been
dress-up corners...
-Yeah.
-...in the houses.
-That makes sense.
You have a theater background.
There would be --
-But, also, back to my
childhood, Halloween was great
I grew up
on a boarding-school campus.
My father
was an English teacher.
So it was a very
sort of secure environment
So we were actually able
to go out trick-or-treatin
at a much earlier age.
You know, we weren't reall
going through a neighborhood
We were going through --
across a school campus.
You knew everybody you wer
running into, you know?
-A perfect place.
-A perfect place
for trick-or-treating early.
And, also, it was at a time,
you know, in the '60s
where parents
were a little bit more like,
"Where are the kids?"
-Yeah.
-"Oh, they're out
trick-or-treating."
I mean, they really didn't
even know what we were up to
-Gotcha.
-I don't think my parents
ever really knew...
-What you were really up to.
-...what I was up to.
-Yeah. Did you get in trouble?
Did you take advantage
of the fact
that your parents didn't kno
and get in trouble?
-Well, I mean,
I was so pathetic, actually.
There was --
[ Light laughter ]
I think I had sort of heard with
other friends that, you know
that somehow egg throwing
was involved...
-Yeah.
-...in Halloween
or soaping things up
and everything.
But we didn't really relat
to it in any way.
I just don't remember
really having
a real frame of reference
for that.
Like, really,
what you do with the egg -
Like, what are you gonna egg
you know?
-Yeah.
-We're not gonna egg other kids,
'cause we know all the kid
are our neighbors.
And, frankly, we're walkin
around with them.
-Yeah.
-You know?
So who are you going to egg?
-Yeah.
-So anyway, one --
I remember the first Halloween
where we were gonna
get into trouble.
-Okay.
-Like, that was by design.
-So you -- and that thing where,
as young kids,
you sort of decide
weeks in advance,
"We're gonna cause
some trouble."
-There's conversation about it
-Yeah.
-You know?
[ Laughter ]
-The sort of anticipation
of the trouble,
I think, as a young kid
is more exciting.
-No, absolutely. No, that'
the whole of it, really.
-Yeah.
-And so, there was some
discussion of the soaping.
We really didn't understand.
-I still don't understand
soaping.
-I don't understand soaping.
Anyway...
So, we didn't understand that,
but the eggs, I guess --
My only -- I love eating eggs.
-Yeah.
-And then I knew for the egg -
the egg toss
on the 4th of July.
-Right.
-I knew about that.
-Were you concerned at any point
that you thought
egging was preparing eggs
for people to eat?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-Leave an omelet...
-...and ring the doorbell.
-Yeah.
And then they step in it.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, they step in an omelet
-Anyway, so -- so -- anyway,
we went out with some eggs
-Yeah.
-It was so pathetic.
-What did you end up doing
-So, we go out with some eggs,
and we're taking them with us.
And I don't even know
how we were carrying them.
But, you know, clearly, it was
a lot of like, "Ooh!" you know
-Yeah.
-With the eggs.
[ Light laughter ]
And we took them.
And we went
to the Perkins house.
I mean, Mrs. Perkins -- I ha
sort of a crush on Mrs. Perkins.
I thought she was so --
I mean, I don't know.
Maybe the whole egg of it al
was probably like, you know,
how you'd, like,
kick the girl you liked
sort of in the shins...
-Yeah.
-...at the playground.
-You were --
You were using the egg to flirt.
-I guess.
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
I thought she was great,
you know?
I really --
-You were hoping she'd wake up
and go, "Oh, eggs!"
[ Laughter ]
-I guess.
I don't know what.
I just -- I guess
I just wanted attention.
-Yeah.
-Maybe I wanted to go to,
like, Mrs. Perkins' jail
or something.
-Oh, I see, right, yeah.
-Or I don't know what, but..
[ Audience oohs ]
Anyway, so...
-[ Laughs ]
-...we go to trick-or-treat...
-Yeah.
-...at her house or something.
And we didn't even, like,
throw the egg.
We sort of like dropped it
I'm not even sure, to be
perfectly honest with you --
I mean, it's a long time ago -
I'm not even sure if maybe
we dropped it by accident.
-I see.
-I mean, it really could
have been as pathetic as that.
-And then played it off
as like --
-"Oh, we egged her doormat."
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like...
Anyway, I know an egg, you know,
broke on her doormat
or whatever the hell it was.
Well, so, then,
we leave that house,
and we head off.
And everyone knows
the next house.
I mean,
she knows the next house.
It's the one that's right up
the road, you know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And, of course, the next hous
is the McVays' house.
And Munk is with me, you know?
My -- He's one
of my best friends, Munk McVay
It's his family
who we're going to next.
Well, we show up there.
And his mother
is there at the door, like
"Mrs. Perkins called."
[ Laughter ]
"You get back there
and clean it up."
[ Laughter ]
And I -- It was so depressing,
as, you know, we get there
and she's standing there
with this...
beautiful smile on her face...
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-...and a roll of paper towels
in her hands, you know?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I mean, it was pretty pathetic.
-You guys did not think throug
this crime at all.
-No, I'm a terrible criminal
-Yeah.